Hey, it's me Destin
We got a lot of rain her in Alabama over the last couple of weeks
and i wanted to show you an interesting survival technique i've found in one of the local species.
Anyway, you can see all the area behind me used to be wide open grassy field
but right now.
It's nothing but water
So in order to show you what I want to show you, we're going to have to get in the truck
and drive through the water.
So let's do that now.
[Engine noises, water splashing]
Okay, so...
I found a pretty shallow spot where I could show you this, but you can see
What's normally a field has been covered with water
But in one particular location
We see this clump of this floating stuff and it's hard to tell what it is.
But this dark spot that you see in front of me is actually a bunch of living organisms
striving to stay alive.
They're fighting desperately, actually.
I'll give you a closer look
What you're looking at
is what used to be a colony of ants that would live in the ground.
Here you can see they've clumped up into a raft
with some of them on the bottom
helping the other ones on top float. They've
grabbed on to some grass to try and anchor off and try to get more of them above water.
But if you look real close you can see
it's literally a living raft.
Very interesting survival technique I would say.
You can see they're even carrying their larvae.
After a little investigation, I found out that right under the top layer
That's where... all the larvae are kept.
You see? All the white?
Just under there!
You can see they're scrambling to let all the, uh...
the larvae be on top first
then they encase them with their bodies.
If you notice the ones on bottom, such as right here
These little guys... aren't moving.
Maybe a little grass. Other than that, pure biomass!